i
am a big fan of the purge franchise i've
seen all of the films
every episode of the tv show and one of
the things that i
most appreciate about it is how it
continues to evolve
and this installment clearly is no
exception to that
exactly i think there's some really
interesting elements in this with
the group of people deciding to go rogue
and keeping the purge going the fact
that we get to see the purge happen
during the day
the role mexico plays in the stories so
were those
all were all those things present in the
first script that you read was that
what drew you in were some of those
things added later
yes i think that that's what drew me is
the
baldness and the vision of james
who is very clever and very brave
because he's
not afraid to break his own rules
and that you know that that takes a lot
of
sand and um
and he approached me saying this is the
last
perch movie and i wanted to end with a
big bang you know i wanted to take it to
the extreme
and at the same time i want to get
closer to my original version because
with the success of the franchise it's
been
staring a little bit more into hollywood
and i wanted to be more
you know about the dna of the first one
and i'm like great
i get it you know we can build with that
for sure
and then i just brought a lot of
veracity and authenticity
viscerality to the piece you know i i
informed james on the reality of these
migrants and what they would
actually really be doing and how they
actually would be talking
you know and so that it's believable um
shared a couple of experiences like i i
wanted a scene where
dylan tucker claims that he doesn't want
to hear spanish in his household because
i've heard that in my life
and these are not bad people it's just
that they're not exposed to the culture
so they are defensive
and that's fine it's very game but i
would love i'd love to see the character
that evolved from there to the other
side of the expected spectrum right
um so yeah so most of it was already
there it was just a matter of
we we i love working with james and i i
think it
goes both ways and and and it was very
easy
it was a very easy process of back and
forward back and forward back and forth
yeah yeah and when i spoke to james he
he seemed to really appreciate how
you really kind of called him on the
fact that mexicans don't speak
the way that he'd written the characters
i mean was that was that something up
front that did that make
doing this possible the fact that he was
open to that and
willing to collaborate with you and hear
something like that because there's
probably not
every writer would be okay with that
i i'm a i'm a straight shooter which has
you know
caught me in trouble many times but but
it's the only way that i
know how to be so i love working on that
on
on the truth you know and and it doesn't
hurt
when it comes from the right place and
and it wasn't it wasn't bad writing it
just was
it's not the way we talk so let me
inform you the way we talk
and then you know you'll see how same
idea
you know can be can be more realistic
and more absorbable
for my people at least
so that was great you know all of that
was flawless you know all of that was
super easy to
to work with him yeah he must also be a
really good resource having created the
franchise he probably could answer any
question that you might have just about
the
concept overall for sure for sure
sometimes you have to scratch his head
like why did i
invented that [ __ ] oh yeah yeah all
right but uh but it was like that
no no it was great it was it was great
because
he knew when to be present and and help
the project and when to let go
let the you know let the filmmaker do
his thing and and then come back
to fight the later fights
regarding editing and making sure that
we don't lose the dna of the project
that we created together
so but it was it was a wonderful
experience
how was the editing process for you i
mean was there
a lot of scenes cut out or i mean did
anything
change like and did anything majorly
change during that process
not really it was more about fine tuning
because
the way that i shoot i it's not like i
give options
i have a clear vision of what i want and
i only shoot that so it's not as if
you can later change the movie it just
doesn't work you know
it breaks so so they were cool with that
they were
loving that they were wanting that
because it's a revamp on the franchise
right how can you do a fifth movie with
the same codes and
still be you know on top of the game you
have to break
break some rules and be bold and
make something much more cinematographic
and grab the tone of the actress and
center it to more
realism so that it's more frightening to
me
anyhow you know so so there was a lot of
room to do all of that and then
and then he was championing all of those
things
which did make some people you know
scratch their heads you know
saying oh this is really different from
other perch movies and he was like yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's why we like it
because it's still the codes and people
who
love the franchise won't be disappointed
it's not as if i broke the rules you
know
he broke the rules but uh
you know what i mean like it's still a
solid horror thriller movie
it just has a couple of extra layers
you know i i love that this
film has something of a last stand
moment as they're essentially
you know running this gauntlet of a tank
and explosions
and the shooting how much of that
sequence
is fully written out in the script ahead
of time
how much of that has to evolve once
you're in the environment and can see
what you can realistically do
yeah the biggest challenge on the movie
was definitely the budget because you
read on a screen page
america collapsed and then you look at
the budget and you say how many extras
did you say i could have for that scene
30 what you know how am i gonna do that
so
it made me go back to spielberg not the
spielberg from 100 million dollars right
now but the original spielberg from jaws
where
because the shark kept on breaking down
it's so terrifying
it's so terrifying because you don't see
the shark yeah so we have to choose our
battles and through
see through windows little you know our
20 extras doing their thing
and then you believe that the whole
universe is you know
around them when it was only that right
so we have to be very inventive and very
clever on how to use
the resources so that we can because if
we lose that that was i was afraid the
whole process of losing scale you know
because if you lose scale
if you for some reason don't buy into
the
collapse of america then the movie goes
nowhere you know if you start second
guessing that
it's it's hard to continue
you've done quite a bit of work as a
director on television
did that affect or influence your
approach to this at all did that help
you
with working with the budget and really
just having to figure things out
yeah i think that you always are
learning and the day that i don't
arrive in set and on a daily basis and i
don't learn something
i should retire right it's it's you have
to be open to the
machinery and the beauty of of the
experience of filmmaking how
tough and how fragile it is at the same
time you know to find those moments with
the actors and
tap into that truth is really magical so
all of the baggages all of the projects
come
handy you know one after the other and
this movie helped me do
the next project and that project is
going to help me do the next one
but yeah definitely some experience on
tv
helps you cope with uh the days that you
have to
shoot faster and that you have less
resources and then you
need to improvise for sure yeah you
directed a couple of episodes of one of
my favorite tv shows with banshee
how was your experience on that show
what's it like to come into a show
in its fourth season and still find a
way to bring yourself to it
it was great because um i always come
strong to episodic tv you know and i
think that they're
that's why they call me because i i
truly bring a cinematographic experience
and
try to make it you know as
a cinematic a cinematographer you know i
you know try
let's try to make it into a little movie
you know and people love that because
competition is so brutal out there on tv
that
if you're not top quality you go nowhere
right so
so and actors love it and i love so so
it's
that show was crazy and great and it was
my first show in america
so i was i was greener
and so i had my moments of oh this is
the way the machinery works
okay um but um but it was a great
experience
yeah do you have any idea what you want
to do next how
how has doing this film influenced you
do you want to stay in film for a bit
i love to swap when i love i i think
that um
my northern star is my daughter and i i
believe that
we as parents have to have the
responsibility to try to
leave the world a better place for them
as a species we're failing but in my
household i can make a difference so i'm
always driven by the content not by the
money not by the bling not by
who's attached is the content is what is
the story we're telling what
does it have a message or it does not
have a message
um so i don't i don't i don't care if
it's tv or if it's
a movie as long as i can keep doing both
i'm happy you know because both have
their merit and
you know i'm doing a mini series then
i'm gonna do the whole thing for
you know for netflix and i love those
kinds of projects because it's like
making three movies into one
i really enjoyed making the first season
of mars which i directed the whole thing
on my own and
i love those type of projects where
you're in control of a big boat
and um and it's like making a couple of
movies together
so yeah can you see what that project is
that you're doing
not yet soon very soon
you mentioned your daughter being your
northern star
you have some very strong female
characters in this film
is that the inspiration behind that
it's in between my mom um and my
daughter
um my mom who unfortunately recently
passed she
she passed like two weeks into
production so it was
it was a crazy time for me um
and she was that she was you know that
this really strong beautiful
human being curious about the other
inclusive challenging the rules
pushing us to be better persons so so i
have a really
great role model and i and i want to see
more of that that was very important to
me for
adela to be this 40 year old you know a
woman in her 40s
that she can both kick ass and think
and and and carry his you know carry her
whole family through an ordeal
i won't see more of that on the movies
it's always either the young
the youngest beautiful lady or the
grandma but you know life is not like
that so i won't see more of those
beautiful strong characters i'm drawn to
that immediately and i
i know exactly what to do with that yeah
i really love that because especially
with a film like this
i mean usually it's the other way around
and i love how
the men sort of needed to rely on the
women to get them through this
i love that as well that's that's true
in my experience so
another thing that's really important
and vital to the purge franchise are the
purge looks
and in this film we get purge bunnies
and purge cowboys and even some perch
construction workers
what was it like to get to design those
looks
and and to really figure out what you
wanted because it seems quite often with
those characters we don't get much
dialogue their look is what speaks for
them
sure i think that what's really
successful about the franchise is that
because they wear masks
you are projecting your own horrors
behind those masks right
so that's why it's so scary because you
imagine the worst version of that person
not the best you know yeah because it's
your own fear
so it's a lot of fun and sebastian was
crucial on on fine-tuning that and
guiding me through the process
of juxtaposition and how you know
if you wanted to be scary birch wise
it has to be a little bit off and a
little bit funny
and therefore let's do a little bit of
the rabbits and
and i want to honor with the rabbits i
want to honor a plot line that we
dropped
from the original script but james was
wanting to
talk a little bit about you know how we
consume meat
excessively as a species and all of that
and all of that subplot organically
didn't have room because
you know our universe was contained and
that was like a pink thing in the whole
thing
so we dropped it but i want to honor his
vision
and so i went let's do something that
has to do with butchers and
what could be more frightening than a
stupid bunny
with a goat trapping you
i don't know what to do
i like how they were full looks i mean
it really was
they were full all-encompassing looks it
wasn't just a mask
yeah exactly exactly which which was
great you know it was great to
to explore that explore the cowboys to
explore the you know
the workers which of course would be
people purging
in that universe you're angry you have
to pull cables you're going to
you know make your hammer be felt
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it i really dug the movie so thank
you so much
thank you for talking to me about it
thank you so much